oh and then after looking I gh7 okay  Bishop D3 plate does this allow  they finish this point this takes takes  we should be four and he wins material  back exactly  so what is that Rook G7 exists C7 yeah  exactly and you just take with the  bishop and go Bishop F6 of course  oh this is over  yeah and Bishop E4 check that look seven  to G2 back and we win  Checkmate stress over we'll create is a  Checkmate thread and this  picks up enough material black wins some  backward Bishop E4 well it's not enough  to survive not enough yeah I mean this  is the this is the typical game when you  feel like up loss is uh absolutely  Justified that's it Abu subtle of  designs brilliant played by Magnus  Carson amazing  game of the day so far I might have to  do a game of the day video this is it no